salut dans cette vidéo aujourd'hui vous
entendrez ça les cochons de spike
copains vous verrez ça tourne toi loïc
est un moment donné en grâce à toi dans
ma tête je dis frites mayo ça fait très
longtemps sur cette chaîne qu'on n'a pas
fait un jeu de société j'en reçois
régulièrement et il n'y a pas très
longtemps l'a reçue pigeons pigeons et
d'autres jeux d'ailleurs de cette gamme
la de cette marque là mais aujourd'hui
on va jouer à pigeons pigeons parce que
c'est très cool et on trouvait que ça
n'allait pas mal aussi sur une chaîne de
mentalist donc merci à eux d'avoir
envoyé ce jeu et de sponsoriser cette
vidéo pigeons pigeons c'est donc un jeu
on doit bluffé les autres en leur
faisant croire que des réponses qu'on
propose sont crédibles et c'est des
réponses à des questions que nous pose
le jeu c'est pour ça que je bluffe
on se fie jaune un petit peu les uns les
autres donc il me fallait pour ça des
invités qui qui sont bons dans l'impro
qui sont bons dans le jeu qu'ils sont
bons dans le bluff
quand des petits talents de mentalisme
ont accepté de venir aujourd'hui
vérino le lac d'uby nuit et loïc lagarde
a calmé ouakam à une partie de pigeons
pigeons ça dure entre 15 et 30 minutes
après ça dépend un petit peu la qualité
des équipes c'est un jeu qui est
fabriqué en france dans une petite
imprimerie et ça ça fait plaisir
et évidemment que j'aurai le lien vers
le jeu dans la description si jamais
vous voulez en obtenir un donc je vous
explique rapidement les règles pour voir
comment ça se passe en gros vous faites
en individuel ou par équipe
on pioche une carte sur lequel il a
marqué un truc du style en 1492
christophe colomb a découvert trois
petits points et en dessous il ya la
réponse en gras donc l'amérique
une fois que vous avez lu ça tout seul
ou avec votre collègue parce que vous
jouez en équipe vous avez une feuille
sur lesquels vous marquez la vraie
réponse mélangé avec d'autres réponses
que vous avez inventé donc elles peuvent
être drôles mais si elles sont trop
drôle les autres vont savoir que c'est
pas ça la réponse
le but c'est qu'ils se plantent en fait
qui mise sur la mauvaise réponse
pourquoi miser
parce que chaque équipe pour chaque
joueur à 16 jetons et à chaque coup ils
doivent miser tous les jetons sur les
réponses c'est à dire qu'à trois
réponses qui s'offrent il ya 16 jetons
on peut faire au lean tout sur une
réponse mais si c'est pas la bonne
réponse on la perd tous ses jetons
on peut les répartir sur les 3 réponses
et on va perdre tous les jetons qu'on
n'a pas mis sur la bonne réponse c'est
aussi simple que ça c'est extrêmement
drôle c'est parti pour une partie de
pêche an plus tôt cette partie sera donc
composé de deux équipes de deux
personnes ce sera lola qui tirera et tu
seras avec loïc comme ça on change pas
de place chez fed devrait décider c'est
le halal
vous aurez les roses et nous les bleus
celui qui imite le mieux le pigeon
commence selon denis qui aux cadres
aujourd'hui moi je l'espère garénaux
puisqu'il faisait le pigeon non non non
c'est pas bien ce que tu fais c'était un
autre moment j'ai oublié comment on fait
maintenant tu te c'était un bisou
italien denis du mouvement [ __ ] mais
c'est normal c'est ton amour et ben nous
on s'appelle les halls paul ollivier et
au lit car riou lisez big flo et oli
on est au lit au carré olicard est notre
équipe à ton nom c'est parti pour la
première manche sportif en grèce antique
les hommes
il ya beaucoup de choses avec ce maudit
la poterie la poterie salle à potsdam
faudrait trouver un truc un peu marre
marre en réponse et je faisais du sport
tout nu qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait naître
j'aime bien le truc de la poterie presse
parce que c'est un peu tu as et la
poterie tous les sexes toutes
est-ce qu'ils vont franchement je pense
qu'ils signent là on les a bien mais qui
tout au lit au lit au carré genre
bonjour bienvenue
la question est en direct imiter jacques
chirac mais sans faire la juste la
gestuelle la question en grèce antique
les hommes faisait danser sport tout nu
faisait de la poterie tout nu faisait
des olympiades du sexe tout nu alors les
olympiades du sexe habillé franchement
j'y crois très fort
moi je connais la avance aussi c'est
vrai comme beugnon mrs comment vous
pouvez trouver aussi rapidement en fait
moi je m'intéresse à tout ce qui est
sexe et j'ai jamais entendu parler d
elle inquiète du sexe opposé les
intérêts sentence est tombée messieurs
dames j'espère tellement qu'on a faut
tellement on est sûrs de nous c'était
qu'il faisait du sport tout nu
écoutez c'était une tentative c'était ma
première partie on fait une tentative un
échec je pense vraiment qu'il faut dire
les choses c'est à partir d'un moment on
peut commencer la vidéo maintenant parce
qu'on a toujours autant que je tombe du
coup nous confessionnal allez zou
propose cette carte sis question les
cochons ne peuvent pas moi je connais
plein de choses qui peuvent pas se
brosser les dents prendre un coup de
soleil à regarder le ciel auquel peuvent
pas faire ça ils peuvent prendre un tir
day comme les hommes ont fait le plein
et du coup on va mettre les coups de
soleil ça sonne vachement bien réponse
une honte de coûts' des coups de soleil
ça j'aime bien qu'on me demande combien
suivre je mettrais bien au milieu -
est-ce qu on précise que c'est la bonne
réponse
ouais on met des coeurs autour des îles
ne pas construire des maisons en paille
vous savez les gens où ils ne peuvent
pas vivre à plus de 25 ce qu'il ya un
côté un peu les cochons il faut pas
qu'ils soient trop opaque copains est ce
que tu peux le faire comme une vérité
niveau au le vivre eux m'a plus de 25 à
l'état sauvage
c'est bon ça y est les nouveaux resté
impassible
laurence resté impassible owens et
messieurs les lolos les cochons ne
peuvent pas prendre des coups de soleil
et flèches regarder le ciel vivres à
plus de 25 à l'état sauvage pour il
pourrait pas regarder le ciel pays l'ont
fait
non mais les gars sont légalement même
s'ils n'ont pas levé la loi du cochon
elle m'a déjà livré plus de 25 années à
l'état sauvage
loïc on parie sur quoi moi je mettrais
un peu disent y ait un peu aussi le
regarder le ciel tu me sens pas mais tu
peux quand même qu'on mène deux au cas
où c'est écrit comme ça on ne perd pas
quoi c'est parti la réponse vérino est
la réponse était la réponse 2 regardez
j'ai cru qu'on allait y remédier il me
fallait faire
mais oui en un conte avait tellement
raison le 8 mai déplaire un poste alors
ça ça vient de copains comme cochons
rançon ni d un séjour à les bars et où
la route est encore dans la partie
attends je vais enlever ça parce que du
coup je vais mettre là pour qu'on voit
bien que c'est plus house est l'auteur
de l'oeuvre musicale intitulée les choix
le cul et mozart la réponse parce que
vouloir mettre un truc genre à patrick
sébastien c'est un peu un jardin didier
super super l'instant il a fait un truc
dans ton fier parce qu'on les traite pas
sur un truc ont bétonné comme ça ça
allait mais après c'est peut-être le
sait les indique que c'est peut-être un
des deux ou alors si on les a brain en
faisant croître moi je n'y a pas été
très malin ce qui est en train d'être
bit au voleur c'est bonjour bonjour
l'auteur de l'oeuvre musicale intitulée
lèche mois le cul ouais patrick
sébastien
mozart beethoven vraiment tu sais quoi
je crois que c'est mozart ambre à 99%
j'ai un vrai truc en tête de mozart café
un trucs délirants vraiment très
vulgaire regarde leur réaction dès que
j'ai dit mozart
ils ont été sous les monts gâte un
mélange de cultures et de mentalisme qui
me fait dire mozart je te propose lui
jetons pour toi et vite pour moi ok
d'accord et chacun les classes si tu
vois c'est une belle démocratie ce qu'on
fait c'est un bel exemple de démocratie
donc quand même je te fais confiance
quelle est la réponse la réponse est oui
qu'on peut écouter un petit extrait en
civil notre et des gens regardent
on
benjamin pas du beau tournoi week end et
bien fuyez pauvres vient te laisse au
jjda balle d'albertville en 1992 il y a
eu une épreuve de danse sur ce qu'ils
vont alors déjà on le met où dansent sur
ce qu'ils ont le mais comme ils ont
mieux effet des coeurs une épreuve de
quoi alors jo d'albertville en 92 un
truc avec du curling sur pente
j'en fus tout est comme ça tu le laisse
glisser longtemps et tu vois où il
arrive des fois au contraire font
remblayer quoi qu'il arrive de glisser
biathlon aérien entre parenthèses pas à
tout ça ça ne vous reste moi je voterais
pour lui c'est bon question
la question est la suivante aux jo
d'albertville en 1992 il y a eu une
épreuve de curling en pente de dents sur
skis de biathlon aérien parachuté sic en
ligne en pente ça n'aurait pas de sens
de la danse sur ce qu'ils ont sur ce qui
est certain c'est que je compliqué et
l'autre ses billes et n'en est rien
c'est un peu style est d'arriver en
parachute
c'est parce que j'adorais intitulé est
ce qu'on peut danse / ce qui dans ces
trucs pour moi dans ma tête je dis
frites mayo donc vraiment la bonne
réponse est claire les normands pente
[Musique]
maintenant sur six que c'est juste des
mouvements du placement sur ce qui se
croient pas de bombe à faisons ça on
fait tout a vraiment rien le bien contre
le sens pas très bien alors dans ce cas
là loïc jeté sur la réponse est dense
sur ce qui est pas mal
[ __ ] j'ai les boules il était
tellement loin des par là franchement
léviathan aérien il était où il était
passé ta etienne etienne mountain
allégorie les jeux de société pour les
enfants dont le nom est un deux trois
c'est comme quand on est jeune même tout
sur l'a31 trop et l'écueil du cochon
pascal couchepin amoureuse que du cochon
c'est carrément grand duc c'est par un
jeu pour enfants de trois forêts
un truc genre un jeu dont avec un réseau
social pour le jour tik tok en tap tip
top basique chose c'est une idée dont
les commentaires n'hésitez pas bien
entendu non mais là que du cochon c'est
très bien c'est bon c'est pas mal
mayonnaise ketchup mayonnaise alors il
existe un jeu de société pour enfants
dont le nom est là que du cochon tic tac
tic toc 1-2-3 prout
moi j'aurais bien loin de 3 prauthoy
tic-tac tic-tac y avait pas d avoir un
tic-tac-toe la queue du cochon ça
n'existe pas ça non c'est le cochon qui
rit déjà il ya marqué que c'est un jeu
de bluff
hilarant est ce que ces gars en la queue
du cochon aux tic tac tic toc
non à les en croire deux trous 9 oui
c'est ça c'est hilarant donc ça là le
blog rien c'est pas du coup on a quatre
matches
lahouel à chauffer ok allez vas-y
il existe un jeu de société pour enfants
dont le nom est de 3 prout ska tous
quatre allers
je prends plus facile ce jeu quand on
connaît la face avant christophe
salengro le président de la présipauté
de groland était mai mais quelqu'un m'a
mis que quelques messages si le ca s'est
ouvertement de la triche dont elle a
obligé d'en laisser ça ok mêmes
quéquette mai mais kate pickett ça si
jamais tu vois ça c'est à dire que c'est
bon le [ __ ] ah c'est bon la question
est la suivante n'a trop de jetons avant
christophe salengro
le président de la présipauté de groland
était ma mick et keith mémé quéquette
oumamar quéquette sûr mais mais toi tu
parles
mémé quéquette moi j'avais j'avais le y
quelque part alors dans ce cas là mais
le bas mais après c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils veulent pas perdre quand tes
impressions tu t'accroches mais c'est
vrai un nom il faut il faut accepter la
réponse et mamie quéquette oh [ __ ] le
heat avec qui j'avais entendu la star
des soutiens en soit voici dans cette
première manche les statistiques sont
claires nous menons loïc ont secouru et
tu t'imposes prix ça la prochaine bien
sûr c'est parti pour la deuxième manche
le chilien me milenko boucau vick a une
particularité il n'y a plus de 80
tatouages sur le corps tableau mais il
ya plus de 80 90 concentré tous âges
on va les voir suis là je vais essayer
dans le regarder dans les yeux non c'est
très mauvaise idée de faire sans ces
bonbons halal a fait manger un sandwich
il s'en tape quoi j'ai regardé de notre
question le chilien lequel milenko
bucolique a une particularité il a plus
de 80 tatouage de julia roberts sur le
corps c'est très très drôle il a plus de
90 d'appui à la laisse aller ou pas ils
ont utilisé la technique et ben moi j'ai
envie de dire que de toute façon il faut
répondre plus de 80 parce que quoi qu'il
arrive et un oral de livres 90
s'il en a cent d'ici là + 4 dans cette
réponse convaincu les deux autres 6 3l
vrai alors c'est vrai c'est vous qui
avait créé le
le parador laquelle laquelle at on créé
un peu importe puisque à partir du
moment où il ya plus de 80 mais vous
réfléchissez beaucoup trop on répondre à
la question normalement voter en
commentaire pour cette logique s'il vous
plaît est-ce qu'on a raison on va venir
et je mettrai ici ici plus de 90 ça veut
rien dire toi où il a plus de 80 en mode
c'est beaucoup ça me fait une réputation
où il a plus de sens eu dispute a enfin
passé laissant était partie il ya plus
de 80 tatouage du maire robert quand il
a dit j'ai tapé do allez ciao
qu'est ce que la parure esi s'est donc
l'incapacité de faire pipi quand on se
sent observé
parce qu'on met du pipi donges est de
montrer cette vidéo à mes enfants est ce
que ce serait pas un trouble du
comportement qui fait que tu as bien
faire votre pardon ou le feu ne les voit
pisser sur quelque chose
oui c'est sûr un art glisser sur wiiware
peut-être plus la roque à la grand-mère
des cibles des cibles apparentements
voilà pas le à des temps un bruit d'eau
ouais t'as raison ça se déclenche tu
peux ok ça y est les enfants
benno j'en appelle à la question qu'est
ce que la parure hésité mais qu'ils je
sens je mettrai tout sur l'a23 j'ai déjà
entendu ça une fois que je n'imposerai
plus mais maintenant je moi que moi
alors aller voilà ont fait 55 sur ok et
bien c'est l'incapacité de faire pipi
quand ils se sentent observés
on aurait pu faire le lait la jouer des
flous tu as les marais abandonné 1 kas
là on va la tac tac toe toit doré un
équivalent large aurait pas pris cette
pièce mais la baisse on est là c'est
très très bien je note ça j'ai
l'impression de faire une ordonnance
c'est bon céline dion à 14
13h13 s'addresser 9 à la soeur moi
j'allais y sont 14 soit elle l'a 14 mai
j'ai entendu qu'elle a une famille avec
le 14 de regard mais là il a encore
hésiter l'absent il est pas non plus
nickenig il regarde en fait il a
commencé par écrire ça ouais et après il
a fait ça et ça comme on n'est pas en
études de cartes spéciales tout et sur
la réponse de moi je dis je dis aux
livres est ce que tu veux tu peux
m'expliquer par vous tous résolus à dire
que vous avez lu vous avez fait ça et
ensuite vous avez réfléchi ce qu'on lit
pas au début plein de faiblesse
puisqu'il avait donné c'était on regarde
la carte on ne lit pas la réponse et
vous avez répondu avec des trucs avec
des tracteurs la plus grande fan de
céline c'est vrai sans blaguer par
céline dion a très récemment versé
inverseur version va ça c'est du
mentalisme c'est même plus de la culture
tout à l'heure ils s'arment finish pas
il peut pas voir si j'écris ça d'abord
il ya les ibadou with lady voulons les
images maintenant c'est possible
avec ces techniques d'orthèses peut voir
que j'ai c'est facile de faire ça j'suis
pas l'énerver d'accord mais nous on
passe un bon moment je comprends pas ce
que vous reprochez les grecs la femme de
zeus et héra déjà sacré la voie lactée
avec les deux sens sainte marie selon la
mythologie grecque tu la femme de zeus
et à la voie lactée avec le led sont
tout à fait sûr mais un all in nature
ballin sur la bien tu peux te lever puis
te ra soir car la réponse est la bonne
réponse
on s'est fait chier sinon tu as mais
cela nous a pris le vix aval à ses pairs
et soeurs pour tous les enfants que tous
avaient bouffé hier je vais vraiment et
c'est là qu'on se croit de la même
manière que lui et là je ferai genre
temps ferait peut-être un truc quelques
les chevaliers du zodiaque
au lieu de commencer au passé simple du
méthane un parfait n'a pas le même
maillot mais une passion avec une
majuscule aux dépens et audrey et donc
les deux derniers ingurgité manger sa
descendance ouais j'ai envie d'y croire
sanaa alors là ils sont la question est
simple et rennes-2 ursache et la sainte
patronne des femmes de ménage des
presbytères c'est très pointu suis là
ils mettent un all in en arrivant vers
vraiment efficace on peut mettre des
taxis des jardiniers
ou des pupilles la nation hockey depuis
qu'une fois la troisième déchets à faire
du soin super mec juste de ce oui c'est
vrai qu'on aurait inventé presbytère et
bien sûr des ébénistes parti orthodoxe
s'il vous plaît alors vous êtes prêt ou
pas alors monsieur oui ça ne veut rien
de zurzach c'est la sainte patronne des
pupilles de la nation femme de ménage
des presbytères extrémistes
art ébéniste non très énervé moi je sens
la réponse trois jeux à 100 regarde
regarde le peniste orthodoxe c'est quoi
on va en mettre un là et là pour
continuer à jouer grâce colline sur et
bénisse ortuno presse colline
c'est vraiment un sang neuf et rennes de
girac et la sainte patronne des de
ménage de président il a baissé la tête
qu'est ce qu'un vrai quoi un habitant de
la ville de feurs savoir qu'est ce
qu'elle sait du cas d'eric way à quoi
qu'est-ce qu'un verrue quoi les
habitants de la ville 2 pouces tu t'es
dit sur toutes ces propositions le plus
logique et la vidéo ça existait c'est ou
sur la plante des pieds à côté de moi
autant aller c'est ça nous a virés quoi
est un habitant de la ville le verrez
c'est la balle de match quand on roule à
la rivière qui fait office de frontière
mode de rum and on appelle le brut
atteint 2 3 des références au jeu tu as
simon laiterie contre est vraiment les
batanga frites avec 1h et c'est très
bien ça là on est très bas d'un très bon
état ces bons messieurs la rivière qui
fait office de frontière moldau roumaine
s'appelle plus aucun ça c'est bon ça
j'aime ça
là vous êtes
gagnants s'ils ont une idée c'est qu'ils
se sont dit on peut mettre le h à
d'autres endroits
ou alors il s'en dit on même truc et il
faudrait qu'on l'écrive autrement web on
va pas mettre un oscar freire mon compte
on met une lettre silencieuse il aurait
bien eu un avenant poker on est sur les
deux premiers à temps parce que ça le th
peut vouloir dire il peut y avoir une
prononciation
non mais je le mettrais là dessus parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on a le plus de
chance de me prononcer quand on lit sur
moi j'ai confiance en toi
pauline sur le brut réponse le thé le
plus thiès non sans talent sans leurs
troubles aux citations du brevon méfaits
de morzine troisième manche une mort
subite avec un injuste ont chacun un
jeton chacun reconnaît avoir subi c'est
parti pour la mort suivie à pompéi
personnes savaient que les vésuve était
un volcan ne savait parler italien n'a
été incinéré je suis allé à l'expo et il
me semble qu'ils s'y attendait pas du
tout à l'explosion du volcan qui s'y
attendait pas mais qui savait que c'est
un volcan
moi je dirais la 1 mais je suis pas sur
toi tu penserais qu'on ne savait pas
parler italien s'est installée mais
peut-être qu'à l'époque les romains
épanouie par les politiques puisque sur
les murs étaient des gens du latin ou un
truc dans falloir être très très mois
le fils de la chanteuse ashlee simpson
s'appelle brune bagheera bronx mowgli de
manhattan
[ __ ] brooklyn bagheera sap est
tellement en fait bronx mowgli ça sonne
vraiment on a cherché un truc qui
collait avec brooke et une bagarre à
manhattan jones à peine etc sommes là
c'était manhattan
ils sont dix un des quartiers de new
york tu vois ans et trois des cinq
quartiers
eh ben on s'oublie pour faire croire que
c'était broken bagarre à terme manhattan
jones donne la réponse en même temps on
va pas prendre je te laisse nous dira si
nous avons bon ou pas bon que oui non si
c'est vraiment le nom de nous c'était
mieux son nom quand même on a faim c'est
quoi la réponse était il savait pas que
c'était un bol quant à brad pitt et moi
je l'appris là je savais pas non plus je
me dirai ce qu'on n'a pas été très
mauvais sur le fait que quand même
personne ne savait parler italien c'est
peut-être bien car on a raison en fait
on a gagné
ben voilà il parlait pas italien donc on
a bon ouais mais c'était pas la réponse
attendue vous savez quoi c'est les
commentaires qui vont départager mais
nous d'accueillir un grand gagner contre
eux conclure cette vidéo disons que
c'est un jeu de bluff
hilarant merci beaucoup à vous qui
regardez cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
commenter pour savoir tout d'après vous
quelle est l'équipe gagnante ou est ce
qu'on a fait match nul pour moi ce match
nul après leur mauvaise foi fera le
reste
merci à l'aula du bim idée devenue jeu
avec n'est aujourd'hui le là tu sort
bientôt ton album puissant le monde
album le 9 avril
le single lui est déjà sorti le single
est déjà sorti web qui s'appelle
pourquoi on s'aime pour étouffer de
partout sur apple musique sur spotify
sur l'isr est compris dans la
description fabien olicard dans sa
biographie est également et dans tous
ses livres
loïc lagarde que vous retrouvez sur son
instagram ainsi que sur twitch mais sera
disponible dans la déception c'est déjà
sorti tout seul je suis fan de louis
vous tapez vers une vidéo google où vous
allez dans la description et vous avez
la chaîne de vérino et depuis ça se
mérite non mais tu sais ça sans rien
trouver
depuis la chaîne de vernon vous trouviez
son instinct son site internet merci
beaucoup avec jean pigeon mais de
résultats de qualité j'ai dit de rien du
tout parce que j'avais fractales et
remercie le jeu ça ce jeu vous le
trouver dans les boutiques de jeux sur
le site de pigeons pigeons à la fnac sur
amazon donc merci beaucoup à vous allez
bien dans la description vous pouvez
vous abonner à cette chaîne youtube via
le bouton d'abonnement par le bouton et
la cloche c'est très pratique avec
tarder leaké cette vidéo ici je vous
mets deux vidéos là c'est une vidéo avec
vérino on faisait un jeu de rôle c'est
une série de cinq vidéos qui est très
cool si vous savez pas quoi faire durant
le 3ème confinement c'est là et là je
vous mets une vidéo d'un jeu que nous
avions fait avec le la du bini qui
s'appelait menteur menteur et qui était
la première vidéo que le lagarde a
tourné et monté
tout est lié vous la prenez soin de vous
ciao